thank you
[Music]
this is going to be a very special
episode because I like special all we're
gonna do is say congrats to Wong Fu for
20 years wow
20 years long
20 years man that's tight yeah so they
started
in 2003 wow yeah yes at UCSD huh what
did you guys 2007 what was the first
thing that you guys did with Wong Fu oh
wait what was the first thing the first
thing you collaborated on I don't think
we actually
collabed on a video have we however no
they they had us on Asian Bachelor oh
yeah yeah yeah we did that Steve was on
that yeah yeah
you run that too no oh yeah I think so
[Laughter]
but I don't even remember I wait did
they shoot Ryan's thing Ryan higa's um
best crew thing
were you guys a part of that uh no no
wait they did uh girls on the dance not
girls that's the first thing we do
that's like Michael Jackson yeah we did
this Far East Movement had a song called
dance like Michael Jackson back in like
2000 I want to say seven or something
something seven or eight and then uh
Philip was I don't know if all of Wong
Fu did it but I remember Philip was
there and then that was the first time
that we worked with them we did the
music video for it it was like Quest
Crew Far East Movement and Wong Fu like
the three together yeah
that was the first thing
yeah I don't know I feel like we they
they had us uh play a something in
whatever but just a bunch of like random
I remember being in a music video with
uh David Choi and KevJumba
I forgot Ryan Higa was in it oh what was
that that's the first time I saw Anthony
in in person I think oh really
I was like this fact I love to smoke
cigarettes
because he was fat and he just kept
smoking he kept smoking cigarettes in
between every [__] take
I'm like damn dude you're supposed to
stress the [__] out I think that's
really that's what they do right that's
really what you thought that then yeah
man this is
funny because you would never think
that's Anthony yeah a fat smoker I was
like that doesn't describe him at all my
favorite is like uh when they have you
know because they have Boba mofo yeah
very nearby very good and now like
um because these guys are always ripping
on uh Wong Fu like when I first came
there'd be like jokes and [__] and then
uh I think one time you were like saying
that all right guys if any of you guys
are in the area you need to take a [__]
[Laughter]
after we went there to I guess we got
drinks there after one of the adventures
the stinky tofu yeah
like don't even go there for the drinks
just you
totally again you just clog it up
it's very good really good I like their
teeth because it's a spin on uh like
Taiwanese food with like modern Fusion
oh I didn't know so it's like it's like
one of my favorite things they had up so
they have like a bolo sandwich thing
which is like a you know like the Bola
bow and they make like a but they use
like like the Nashville Fried Chicken in
the middle that was crazy good I had
their uh like mapo tofu but instead of
maputo it's like Maple tater tots so
they did they'll take like Taiwanese
things and spin it with American it was
really really good my favorite thing was
so they came out with the video uh
recently kind of like commemorating
their 20 years and even though you know
how many people they've put on through
the years you will still be like that's
more than I thought like because they
put it all in a row and you get to see
just like everybody in there you know
like uh like Kina Grannis like like a
lot of people's introduction to so many
of these Asian artists and actors
honestly was Wong Fu like it's pretty
it's pretty trippy like C moves on there
of course you guys now uh you your own
Asian Bachelor with them I think
weren't we you did the first one I did
the first oh okay I did the second one
you did the first okay it's cool to see
like that was like a reunion kind of
yeah that was cool like seeing everyone
just wait yeah yeah
also they they did Isa right which was
so good like yeah and we performed that
like a few isps there was nothing really
during that time except for
collaboration that brought Talent
together in a community yeah even the
ISA basketball games oh yeah oh that's
them huh that was them the charity
basketball events yeah they really did
put a lot of like people on from that
specific Community I don't know if it
was Kev Jamba or them but then we all
did a soccer game for charity event too
yeah but no one watches soccer so
yeah it's dope if you guys have have a
moment like check it out it's just uh
the video's like four minutes long but
it just shows everybody enroll you just
like remembered how uh how everything
looked back then like like seeing Kathy
Nguyen in video and see dogs and like
yeah just all them like seeing them in a
row for the years even like Harry shroom
and like just it just like really is a
nice nostalgic dose they really did it
for like the Asian American culture they
do and they've stuck to it and that it's
still like what they're about now yeah
and they're seriously like you know how
they're brand a nice guy right and it's
like yeah right like are you really no
it's like no no they genuinely are nice
[__] people and like
and um even though Ted went off to doing
his own thing like every even like just
individually they're like genuinely cool
ass nice folks right yeah so this is I I
this I mean as a fan like I'm just like
I'm sad that like they're not all three
creating content all the time but I know
like even for us
we couldn't
like for JK films right it's like
YouTube making sketches and shorts and
stuff like that like it's hard but they
actually keep doing it yeah and they're
one of the first ones I ever saw do you
know like uh romantic like comedy or
romantic uh things with like Asian
Americans
writing yeah good writing and like
something you can kind of see yeah yeah
that's why I was never casted
I like that they they even put Victor
Kim on like when um when they had that
uh was it a way we oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah they they like gave him a shot
and he wasn't like acting or anything
but then uh they literally approached
him like Hey you want to be this
character and that like changed his
whole like thing like he would he really
like got a big self-esteem Boost from
that
that they they
um showed us like what was possible
because we always get compared to them
because there were only two kind of
YouTube Asian film teams but then all we
were doing was literally like oh Wong Fu
did that cool and later on I found out
from Phil that he was looking at JK like
oh you guys are turning this into a
business and I'm like you did this first
really that's funny yeah like they um
came out with the awkward animals and
they're telling us like yeah merch is
the way to go because during this time
AdSense wasn't making a lot of money
because we're we're just bootstrapping
everything from AdSense and they're like
you guys need to like do merch and stuff
and we're like oh merge and then they
hooked us up with their connect and
that's when we did the Uncle Sam hats oh
wow I didn't know that yeah so the
people that was making awkward animals
you know helped us make some of our
first merchandise and then we got into
all that because that's like how you
feed the art right you need business
behind it so throughout the time that
like it was like Wong Fu and you guys
did you communicate a whole lot
about just what you guys are all doing
not really because it's funny that like
from the outside like we would assume
that because you guys are the people
making [__] I just thought you guys were
talking all the time I think we would
talk for events and talk here and there
but not like
um business yeah not as like like us and
David would talk way more yeah you know
it's almost like we were like the two
Neighbors on the street that talked a
lot I think it was just like we would
talk whenever we ran into each other at
events but I don't think we
um like actually communicated out on a
personal level oh wow yeah well like
Phil will come through and we would
collaborate and then it was always this
mutual respect but I think like
me personally I wasn't very business
minded so it never went beyond like hey
I like you let's hang out and then like
just talk about normal [__] and I'll be
like okay see you next time when I see
you at an event or whatever right but
then it never went beyond that yeah
um but like I think it's because maybe
I felt like they were always busy or
like just you know subconsciously you
think oh they're probably like I don't
want to bother they're always not the
same about you guys yeah whereas someone
like David I'm like you ain't doing [__]
get your ass over here let's go play
basketball
it's different we've had basketball
games with Phil too we did though yeah
you're right we used to play basketball
here um when we had like a whole like uh
like crew and staff probably two or
three times a week and I knew Phil
played basketball because of the ISA
basketball and then I'd come he would
come down and would go play
yeah but I always felt grateful when um
Phil would invite us to stuff because I
know what he I knew what he was trying
to do which is like build up like the
whole Asian American culture and like
have more presence so he didn't have to
but he would always invite us to do like
remember that one thing we shot at uh
the Youtube studio and
Playa del Rey oh yeah like like he would
always like I would always feel him like
try to craft this Asian American
narrative and then in his brain I can
almost feel like well it's not Asian
American narrative without the influence
of JK so even when he wrote that book
he wrote it with uh angry Asian man like
kind of documenting the last 20 years
like he put JK in it too so I would
always felt like he like oh yeah JK has
a huge impact like I'd always feel feel
him try to pull us in which is really
cool I think that's what people don't
know about Wong Fu is like
you might just enjoy their videos and
content but they're actually like
Community Builders like they build like
like a whole platform so like and then
they invite everybody because most
people are like like I'm just trying to
be famous myself or like I'm out here
making films for myself right like us
like we're not building a whole [__]
show and inviting everybody to be a part
of the variety show or whatever like
everyone's just in their own game
whereas Phil I think is like thinking
about how do you build an industry
around this thing we have or like he
thinks on a bigger kind of scale right
yeah
yeah so I think like that was the cool
thing about it is when he's having he
partnered up with like Facebook and like
he would do things like that charity
basketball event Isa whatever annually
and he's always thinking about like how
do you tie this and then build like a
huge audience and then collaborate yeah
and that's what I like loved about it is
it's always this like collaborative like
approach from them instead of like
competitive yeah yeah yeah I felt like
they were always really good at doing
that and it was it was inspiring to like
want to do the same thing with the same
tone yeah yeah to be more like inclusive
with everybody doing the same thing
right yeah and I also think a lot of
people don't have the capabilities that
they did of putting on an event even if
they wanted to because we looked into
the whole economics of it we wanted to
get an auditorium and all that and then
like they were able to get like a t they
were able to get like major sponsors
yeah and I think it's because
the whole nice guy brand like they don't
cuss like there's like it's brand
friendly right when you're brand
friendly you could pull bigger projects
together because more people are willing
to jump on board sure yeah over here
we're talking about [__] rim jobs all
day yeah
and it's kind of hard to get a t jumping
on board you know what I mean like Metro
PCS Maybe
Comedy Central maybe but then I always
felt like uh the way that they were
tying things together with mainstream
and then community building that was a
big inspiration for me because I'm like
oh [__] and then I'm like we can do that
but the degenerate way
[Laughter]
sponsors that will yeah
yeah it's like maybe Bangbus will
sponsor us or like you know what I mean
like we just we're trying to find our
atnt that's actually a good idea you
know it's funny because like like
prepaid T-Mobile
it's just like you said I think like the
same thing happened to us when when we
were like all doing the same uh Asian
Americans in in independent
entertainment Conquest we all thought
everyone was so busy
like the quest girl yeah everybody like
I thought you guys are busy yeah like I
was like you know what I'm not a hood
hopping [__] so when I saw that Kev
Jumba and Ryan Higa and the Yum Yum not
the Yum Yum crew but the yeah yeah and
then they like you guys teamed up with
questions yeah I was like all right
that's that's their click in my head I'm
like that's their that's that's their
game it's just dietrich's victory but
you guys were all purple yeah yeah
that's your fault yeah
well that's all that's purple right that
you guys are you guys are the purple
jackets the the ytf we wanted to create
the WTF ah we got the what the [__] man
because when they look at us they're
like what the [__] I don't want Asian
representation from this group
we're not affiliated with that you guys
are YouTube friends and then the what
the [__] well see that's what's nice
about Wong Fu is that no matter how much
off the rails you went they always made
sure to include you in the credits of
like these guys did 100 I felt always
Unworthy of the inclusion like being
included because I always felt like I
didn't fit in with the normal rib drop
guy I am I don't want to tank the brands
that with your taint no because dude
look at
ISA awkward at like it's cute it's clean
yeah
what we did it was like bro come on man
like that was not cute but at least for
like a Asian like entertainment like
we're all kind of in the same thing so
we're still the same Community you're
still representing it's just like a
different Channel exactly yeah exactly
one's the porn Channel and then the
other ones Sesame Street yes and yeah
yeah yeah congratulations
20 years holding down for Asian
Community just everybody in general
[Music]